welcome to this video yeah this is round
hi coverage of the gushy move memorial
and again a little bit late one day
after the round was played couldn't do
it earlier somebody due to two effects
had something to do in the evening and
this round was full of interesting games
so I couldn't just well post a quick
video them do we are sometimes I don't
know how some other channels or sources
manage to get such a quick quick video
up because well when when do they ever
look at the games before or I know it's
it's tricky i think it's it's just um I
feel like I didn't even scratch the
surface now with what I'm going to going
to present but it is still with sewer
take quite a while because the games
were so full of ideas and possibilities
let's get going with this round and i'm
starting with one game that i'm not
going to cover basically Mammadov
playing whitey against Micky Adams um we
can have a quick look down but there's
not much to really analyze we had a
closed Rui Lopez and mammadov goes for
deform so-called Yates variation it's a
sideline age 3 is more popular the idea
of 83 is that this Bishop g4 move should
be prevented when you have deform coming
so it's a prophylactic move against
Bishop g4 and therefore d4 is answered
with Bishop g4 yeah Black has pressure
against you for now yeah this is still
an interesting line for wide to play we
should be three until we get an
interesting transformation black gets in
c5 and if white now would go for setup
with d5 we have a structure that looks
very much like a Ben Oni yeah I have
some experience on the black side of
this line and TM Adams took this is
something that I usually tend to avoid
early but it's not a bad or anything
it's just a different way to play in
this game wyd
now went with G for pushing the bishop
back and ultimately black got in d5 and
this led to simplifications in the
center wyd always had the slightly more
active piece as we will see how it
unfolded yeah here like this White has
slightly more activity with the pieces
but g4 as a move that is weakening the
King long-term in the game it was a fine
balance between those two factors yeah
animus had to be a little bit cautious
because of the activity as mentioned but
he's a very precise player change
somewhat let's say yeah tidy positions
in position that you can really um can
really calculate properly he sometimes
has his bad moments when it comes to
totally irrational position but if it's
kind of strategically strategical
buildup then he really makes any
inaccurate inaccurate moves and this
happened here they continued for quite a
long as Robert ultimately agreed to draw
here after the the trade we will have
the whole queenside traded and then it's
it's totally dead this wasn't a totally
uninteresting game but the others were
just so full of content that I have
really no alternative to cut this to
basically nothing and let's have a look
at Ankara wanna get next let's let me
find my note says they are awfully long
got a couple of pages here okay Kara
wanna starts with Knight f3 he's not
playing e4 in this tournament it seems
and we have a Catalan Jerry goes for
Bishop before check that's one of the
two main lines nowadays the other being
the open Catalan oops that was a bit
much the other being the open Catalan
the d check c4 or D takes e4 later after
we should be seven and castles the check
is an interesting alternative what black
is doing by inserting the check is
giving Y to the
to move Bishop b2 and this extra move
quite often it's nothing that white
particularly likes to have because very
often the best setup is b3 and the
bishop to be too and that's not possible
with the bishop already on d 2 yeah it's
a well-known variation c6 Quincy 297 I'm
sorry I thought b6 but it was this move
order yeah what black wants to do
ultimately put the bishop most of the
time to a six maybe a rook c8 c5 get the
C file open against the Queen Black has
to solve the bishop c8 problem this is
simply not a great piece and if you
solve this issue get this activated to
trade it and simplify in the center to
to equalize completely like siblings
okay so he tries to go for that Bishop
to a six and now wyd went with a four
yeah this is one of them modern ways to
treat this position in former times
white also played Bishop f4 and 93 those
kind of setups a4 a5 is a newer idea c5
was played and no a five yeah here um
Giri goes for rook c8 which is it seems
a known move in a game run how Peter
nako they also had rook c8 on the board
so it's not not new I was thinking that
also be five might be an interesting
move here but what I didn't put any deep
analysis in there white can take
actually maybe I'm yeah I thori sorry I
read my notes wrong I thought after Luke
c8 sorry rook c8 Queen a2 was played and
now be five that that's what I wanted to
say this I thought was an interesting
alternative to what plate was played in
the game in the game Geary went for 98
yeah white was threatening a b6 and
taking this Bishop so you have to do
something 98
Jake's 693 the whole situation here is
about the rook opposite the Queen White
has the slightly better pieces the rook
opposite the Queen and the bishop on g2
is better placed than the bishop on a
six White has the better pieces in a
situation where there's this huge
central tension it's not a simple
situation for black at all and quite
quickly Geary gets into trouble he took
you on c4 and just Bishop f4 yeah
opening up the D file and getting the
idea d take c5 in and took here with
temple and Queen takes yeah and now we
come to a situation where um the next
move is absolutely crucial it seems
Geary went for which should be seven
yeah Black is a pawn up but white is
threatening d takes my mouse is acting
up the threatening to capture on c5 with
the tempo and this situation is very
awkward for black I think at least this
is what them the engine is recommending
that black probably had to go see for
furs to keep the c5 closed and after
let's say Quincy to play Bishop d7 yeah
white was threatening Bishop takes be a
truck a six so he has to have to do
something Bishop d7 and now after d 5
which is the most promising new I think
after d5 he takes d5 roocase heaven
White has a very substantial initiative
but it doesn't seem that um he's winning
I why Dwight has sacrificed on two pawns
here as mentioned for a big initiative
but it's not flat out winning in the
game after Bishop e7 d take c5 it seems
that um from a purely analytical point
of view if you just view it view this as
a let's say um
yeah i can compute the exercise yeah you
give it to an engine and you probably
have to conclude that white even is
winning but it is absolutely not easy to
play and we will see that Caruana and
had to solve a quite a number of
problems there to really get to a
winning position NAT bd7 was played of
course no alternative and look to a 7
now we immediately see that why it has a
huge pressure but it is difficult to
believe that white should be winning
however it is probably the case but it's
not easy to prove Giri took on f3 that
looks very logical Bishop takes and now
he took with an idea tempo on the Queen
I was thinking what about Bishop c5 in
this position is this an idea the
problem is that what already has ideas
like that when you will win the night
down yeah the pinning situation on the D
file is very awkward also if Y takes
with the pawn you're in this pin will
also lose material so 95 queen to be one
this is all fine um he went back now to
d7 are there alternatives I looked at
night ft seven but then 94 will win this
this material here as 95 is the threat
there's really no way out you can go to
aid but this also loses stones of
material plus a huge initiative why this
winning material but keeps a big
initiative and I thought Queenie eight
maybe but again 95-96 v6 is a problem
something like that for example yeah wyd
will win the exchange and the b6 pawn
back with an ongoing initiative all
pieces are active yeah this is what gear
we played that's the toughest defense
known I'd be five was played that's all
correct and Roxy five young black
doesn't have many moves it seems that
here um there is an alternative or an
improvement this was Caruana smooth the
computer gives Bishop e3 and essentially
it has wide wins yeah I was something
that plus two points something and yeah
well it's all nice and good if you see
it in the seed as the engine evaluation
but how do you how do you prove that why
it is really a win okay if black
retreats the rook White has Bishop
deform with this idea Bishop have six
wins material this is in fact relatively
simple but what isn't so simple if at
least my book is to see that sometimes
that even if black is giving up the
exchange even then why does not just
clearly better but truly winning for
example first glance i thought okay why
not let's say quincy eight let's let's
give up the exchange like this and take
with the bishop this is a well anchored
bishop there on c5 quite often black
would be able to compensate for being
the exchange down but the problem is
that white it's not just an exchange up
with Luke c7 he will win even more
material because whatever you do you're
in deadly pins this will win the whole
night there or alternatively this wins
the night so you're not just giving up
the exchange you're completely giving up
everything basically or you lose more
material is the right right way to
phrase it it seems that Bishop e3 wins
Bishop c7 it's also keeping a huge
advantage but Bishop e3 seems to be a
bit better this is very difficult though
for a human player to a says no matter
how strong the the player is um in this
situation here white still as mentioned
is much better move like let's say queen
bee three or Bishop f4 keeps the
pressure on kawana decided to play
Bishop d6 this is this is
as convincing and we will see soon why
the trade is helping like a little bit
to organize his play after Queen D 894
it looks a very very problematic but
rook c7 is just about saving at the
rookies covering the seventh-ranked wide
of course has some enough initiative to
check to compensate for the pawn like
like here we see that we recover a seven
something like this is winning the night
yeah White's initiative is strong but
it's not yeah it's not enough to win
this this terribly pin in height day it
looks it looks bad but it seems that
there is no no win anymore yeah so after
a while quran i decided to to trade down
and simplify in the position with the
rook and bishop he got some initiative
on the king but he was very alert he
went with 94 that's a very strong way to
completely clarify matters the night is
threatening basically to go back to the
king side and show up the defenses and
after Bishop before which is coronas
move chat or was kiwanis move Black has
this counter attacking idea threatening
mate and white his head doesn't have a
single check so white has to give
material back there there's no
alternative you went queen age 1 and now
after the capture with hisses
simplification to a rook endgame that
was drawn shortly afterwards so a very
narrow escape here for beery who
probably was lost at more than one point
um however this is the kind of thing
where if we go back here this here this
Ned Bishop e3 is ultimately winning this
is something that is not totally simple
obvious for for human player especially
in cases where you win the exchange
very often this kind of winner of the
exchange when there's a bishop on c5
that is cemented by the pawn will not
lead to much but in this case it does
yeah I mean as we see him bishop c7 was
moved at kiwanis spent 13 minutes on and
it seems that Bishop e3 did some somehow
he couldn't couldn't make it work
completely or overlooked to some some
kind of some kind of idea this is a
situation where just reading out them
the computer evaluation is completely
useless as it seems like Kara wanna was
spoiling a very simple win or whatever
it's not the case it was simply am NOT
not that easy okay next game is Mahmoud
yarrow Kramnik yeah again we see this
classical Queens gambit move order by
kramnik and his ideas that while he
accepts the exchange variation of course
this is what we have seen earlier in the
game west they saw Micky Adams while
he's accepting that he also gives
himself more options here on move for
and the option that he goes for is c5
the semi tirage or improved talaash
probably tirage himself wouldn't n think
of this as an improved version he liked
to have the isolated pawn but while
Kramnik has played this before so it was
something that mamedyarov certainly
could have could have expected at least
at 10 as one of the possible lines check
the other check here chatting trains
castles what is developing no it's all
very normal age 6 is not a very common
move but it is some it has been has been
seen before for example the setup was
also tested recently in a game vishy
anand with wide against a car denied it
in the baden-baden tournament in
februari yeah what is the idea of black
setup black has traded two minor pieces
one Bishop and one night and this is
something that is in general quite
favorable for him in this particular
situation because black has less space
and he's not so cramped if he has traded
a couple of pieces with the bishop trade
it quite often you also get a natural
square on natural squares for the Queen
like this and this may be and something
that Queenie seven-night d7 rook c8
could be a setup or you can play with 96
97 this some position and this overall
setup has been known for a very long
time it was always considered to be
slightly more comfortable for white but
in recent years it has been defended
quite successfully by some black players
chromed against one of them there also
some other players who went for that so
it's not something that is it's in your
not a super fashionable line but
certainly something that is on the
agenda nowadays Queen III that seems to
be technically speaking a novelty but
it's a fairly normal way to try to
activate the Queen 96 and h4 gaining
space on the kingside 927 and h5 yeah
this h4 h5 push is a is an idea that we
see em quite frequently in in positions
like that White has a little bit more
space in the center and tries to set up
for an attack on blacks King ultimately
what wide ideally wants to do is to get
this some sort of battery and the bishop
may be somewhere here Queen on d3 Queen
f7 mate this kind of thing in an ideal
world wide manages that and we will see
that in the game
this idea comes into play in general it
takes space and space is very highly
valued nowadays the downside of the porn
age 5 can be that under unfavorable
circumstances it might be a pawn that
can be attacked yeah just imagine a
night on f7 would probably pick up this
pawn yeah black went with Queen d6 and
d5 now by mamedyarov this is a very
well-known idea in this type of position
white is pushing the pawn it looks like
at first he is just blundering this pawn
but that's not the case the idea is that
after he takes d5 white pushes e5 yeah
there's a clear very classic they have
their many classic games in the 60s
where this was played um let me think
about this this is polygraphs keytar not
quite sure there are a number of classic
games there where this idea was played
why this ceiling the long diagonal with
d5 then pushes with e5 opening up the
diagonal of them here white has very
nice strategic compensation for the pawn
he would often go night to deform yeah
sorry about that i have to get a new
mouse it seems it does weird things to
me yeah night probably to deform and
yeah white has attacking chances chromic
didn't didn't take he exchanged and
played rook c8 I think there's also a
very good and practical decision there's
really nothing much to be gained by
taking the pawn with the trade some it
is so much more comfortable for black in
comparison in this situation why it
shouldn't treat this as the more pieces
are traded the more problematic is on
potential compensation becomes if he is
forced to take care for example after
Bishop e6 black is just better this
point is a weakness and the two points
against one porn on the queenside
promised black a good game also now h5
tends to be Rica sure they are with more
pieces traded this have this is the case
so why played rookie one that's much
better keeping pieces on the board again
if black takes you five gives right
compensation it doesn't seem to be
overwhelming for white so it's not
exactly the Kramnik couldn't take but
it's certainly something you don't like
to do giving the opponent and initiative
especially keeping in mind that
mamedyarov is very good in dynamic
position so knotted not a great idea to
grab the part so we went rooks III I
think also preferable north community to
Roxy five he just keeps the central
tension and always having in mind that
capturing it's no problem for blog at
all all these pieces are fine and why
doesn't have any particularly great idea
note that it's really much better to
have not have any poem that I had a
bishop now as a useful role mb 7 ok we
have bishop to be one yeah trying to set
up the mentioned battery and here
kramnik played King to f8 he's just
stepping out of a possible check and
gets the King a little bit nearer the
near nearer to the center Queen d3 as
mentioned this is the idea and rook c8
widest a black is just waiting and now a
3 was played yeah looking at keeping the
beef before square under control and
possibly um setting up for Bishop to a
to ya this is a at least for me slightly
a mysterious moment now because Kramnik
plays the move on 'if I've and while
this is not terrible for black um I
still was surprised that he did that
I don't see a huge incentive to do it at
the moment because I mean white is not
threatening much at least I don't see it
I mean this is probably my bit my my
shortcomings they are coming into play
with I don't see what white is
threatening I mean the computer also
doesn't see much there in terms of
activity I wasn't really sure if white
has something great if I just go rook c5
again I know it looks weird yeah going
back and coming back to c5 but if black
weights what exactly is white white
doing how its might improving you can
play Bishop a two for example no problem
whatsoever but then I really might take
and I'm not sure that this is enough
compensation looks like a dangerous pin
but like an step out there yeah I mean
this is just no threat at all and it can
I can take this checks is always not yet
I'm not not quite sure if if I've was
really a necessary move the problem is a
little bit that now you give wide the
protected person on d5 yeah and you have
to block it with the Queen and it's not
so easy to regroup if for some magic
with some magic trick black hood um
let's say make those two yeah trade
places black would be in excellent shape
but the night is on e seven and the
Queen 96 it's not so not so comfortable
well as we would see it's nothing
terrible for black but well still a
decision that i do question a little bit
to play five i mean at least i didn't i
didn't see why this was necessary okay
but as i said it's not the end of the
world only a little bit later it becomes
quite quite critical g6 Naga Mammadyarov
ya know that he has much more time on
the clock
knight c6 and now we come to the to an
absolute key moment of this game and a
moment where yeah the fate of this game
is basically decided mamedyarov now
played night takes b6 and he did so
rather quickly whatever shocking why is
this even possible yeah Adam the point
is that we will see what the point is in
the game Kramnik did take the d take the
night um the thing is said this is a
mistake after the capture queen bee
three that was the idea Queen g8 mate
yeah I'm like really only has one way to
stop that this is Bishop b6 this this
was played in the game i'm showing you
just the game to get the so that you can
easily compare white now has this pawn
there on d6 and remember this
disposition try to remember this if you
go back here he could have played but
not that's absolutely not easy to see
taking with the Queen that looks looks
like a very scary decision because again
queen bee three as a possibility but
then Bishop e6 is almost look at this
the same thing except for the fact that
there is no pawn on d6 and this
difference is of course enormous it's
just a very crucial pawn that white is
up in the other in the other line so why
didn't he play Queen d6 probably my
guess is that he was also irritated by
this move 9a for this saved the night
with the tempo and the rook doesn't have
many squares but Luke a5 is possible
there is no problem with that move queen
bee three still can be answered by
Bishop b6 I think that Kramnik somewhere
around these lines probably had some
kind of miscalculation it is all hanging
by a thread yeah you know this is really
a narrow escape all the time you get
this back we should be seven and just
about
this move covers covers the night um I
don't know I really don't know what
exactly he he missed them but it's clear
that after a b6 queen bee three there
should be six oops I'm sorry that this
position is very close to a winning one
for white um I'm not completely sure if
it is winning to be honest but it is of
course on yeah very very good winning
chances the pawn is super strong there
on d6 and why it has this some
possibility now to get the rook into the
game and open up the queenside I think
the next or this this sequence is very
very logical yeah like this and c5 was
played 96 check and black and got this
back i did this a bit too quickly after
I have to apologize there let's let's
let's check this wide went a four
blagghhhhh took and rook rook to e8 the
idea is that now rupee 8 is the threat
to promote so black only has one defense
this is f5 takes 96 out both captures
check loose material 926 to cover this d
8 square a3 sending the look back
now it looks like black is getting this
pawn and next move is very important if
what it's not doing that she's returning
this pawn now if why does not doing that
he risks to get into a situation where
he is material up but has no way forward
you had the night coming to have six
this is the issue let's say why does not
doing that and he goes I don't know
something like that lets him here black
might put the knight on f6 and trying to
set up a dark squared blockade yeah it's
very difficult to see how wide should
break through their wide celeste chances
but it's very difficult I think what
Gerald did was better he returned the
pawn and he got black into this very
uncomfortable bind the bishop on f5 was
just very much better than the night and
black has a hard time to move any of his
pieces however I'm not totally sure that
this is really a win because of one
particular thing if we look at this g 3
23 and now Kramnik went 95 I think after
95 he probably is lost I'm not
completely sure if white has a win after
a passive defense I mean nobody really
wants to defend passively but I'm not
totally convinced that white wins maybe
he does but I'm not as mentioned totally
sure there are some ways that white can
try to to play play this position the
main one being to trying to advance with
the King like this yeah 3 to e4 and also
there is the move sometimes Bishop g6
check on this a check on g6 I for
pushing the King back and then entering
with the rook there are some lines there
that they do win for white but it's not
not a force the force issue
example I can I can put something on the
board like this let's say and here it's
no real analysis i know but i just want
to show you some ideas for example here
bishop see to a4 is quite interesting
yeah so check this kind of thing I just
I just want to get to the idea yeah in a
situation where whites king is quite
active here the move Bishop g6 check
this could be a way forward after
Teague's takes wider threatening g7 so
King f8s we played and now white enters
with his King this could be a winning
idea but and what really convinced that
why does some able to force that so
maybe night at eight was a bit a bit
tougher but it's not a move that that
you want to play I totally understand
that chronic didn't play it and I'm not
sure that it saves him anyhow it's
probably still a loss but at least I
couldn't really find a totally clear way
forward after 95 check we see that check
check ultimately after a couple of
intermediate moves the pawn there on age
six is falling at least black got a
little bit of tension reactivity but
it's um yeah why didn't even take that
preferring check stay active and keep
this bind chat forum yeah I know Keane
you three it's important yeah if you
take with the rook check 95 somehow
blackest untangling and well taking with
the bishop check again somehow it's
better to keep this keep this pressure
on King you three check and now take
that's that's a more precise way to take
it check check like could check a little
bit
but ultimately this porn was falling we
had a chat windows chrome Nick was
continuing for quite a while here check
yeah some kind of stalemate defense
check maybe was check what he hoped for
but it's not not happening yeah here why
this is just easily winning with Bishop
to e2 and then you will pick up the pawn
yeah a tricky game this Knight takes b6
idea essentially won the game here this
night takes b6 that was a very good
chance for white that Mammadyarov
correctly yet tried to take with 96 it
was very difficult however to tell that
autumn to evaluate that correctly and
look at from league only had five five
minutes so especially considering i mean
this is a movie certainly thought about
but probably somewhere here he he missed
something or miss evaluated something
it's a very easy thing for the engine to
tell you this is that but it's not it's
not easy to play especially with the
clock ticking down so this means that
chrome dick is back back on fifty
percent score and mamedyarov got his
first win in ok so where are my notes
disorganized him here yeah this is the
next game lenox game is cousin with
white against maxima sheila graph and as
i read on twitter um Carlton hasn't won
against him for about ten years not so
he doesn't seem to be the most
comfortable opponent at least in
classical chest there were a couple of
drawers and I remember that MBR beat him
also in them in the beer tournament some
years ago so let's get going
cars in place this okay something
entirely different not one if one on d4
but he sometimes goes for this very
slowish 93g three setups interesting
also for me because i play that as well
and oh five minutes I didn't know the
clock times yeah like took five minutes
for b5 yeah of course be five or before
is a move to be skeptical about in the
opening but this is one of the cases
where b5 has a pretty decent reputation
actually simply because white is
committed to g3 so the natural way to go
about this beep or move efore it's not
possible here it doesn't make any sense
at least so this is not the same as
let's say Knight f3 p 5 which is really
a bad line I mean I recently had this on
the board and i will show you this game
in the near future this is just bad for
like just just like that be five is a
bad move but with this insert it it's a
different issue if or no it's not
possible and with the somewhat slowish
type of game that that we get it is
justified Bishop g2 yeah note that
causal also took a while so they were
not really playing or click on any prep
here this should be seven and nine eight
three this is one of the ways to fight
this setup when I'm playing this is wide
I very often have played like a density
three and then you for sort of the Kings
Indian attack style it's an entirely
different approach to what cards does to
be honest i like i like what you played
I think it's a very decent way to play
nitey three cakes attacks the pawn a 6c
for that does make a lot of sense yeah
white is attacking the pawn their own b5
and if B form and that was played he
goes to see two and black hands
alternatives here and even some quite
funky one's an interesting move that is
possible here
is he five looks very weird but why not
if we use the pin down on the on the
diagonal and gain some space with black
if white is taking on b5 now Black is
just taking here and here and this is
not a bad position error or a black can
go d6 later 97 b5 is not not a
substantial weakness at all it's a
playable position interesting
alternative ok this is what maxime
played 90 to andy sixx d 485 yeah or
quite normal yeah it's so it's a
position that from blacks point of view
licks looks a little bit like a Queen's
Indian but with pawns verify advanced
and white sari has the night on this
slightly awkward see 2 square so it's a
really original position um yeah what
did Carlton play now he went for d5 this
idea is well known in the Queen's Indian
structures with this where they have the
standoff between the two bishops after
it takes d5 that was not played but
after he takes d5 White has this idea
yeah
opening up the diagonal and therefore
getting the pawn back on d5 there are
possibilities would like to try to hold
the pawn but they are not really great
let's say like this takes here at nine
and five this is a really great position
for white with the huge compensation
yeah let's say castles and a 4 has to go
back Queen g4 there is a pawn sacrifice
line in the Queen's Indian that is quite
comparable and this is a far better
version of that this night will come to
a good place as well later and white has
a very quick and aggressive development
so it's a not a good idea to take the
pawn 9 a-6 94 95 so that looks very
logical it's a good squarely on c5 rook
e1 castles efore so white has gained
some space in the center it still
shouldn't be terrible for black though
if I first played not an easy decision
but it's difficult to allow 'if i for
one year if you give white 'if I've f4
yeah and it looks a lot like a
steamroller you shouldn't do that
probably so I 59 f 5 D 6 all normal and
Bishop g5 by carlson this is a very good
news and it's a very good move for for
one particular reason it done it sets a
dilute trap and well black player here
Maxine Bushido graph he somehow fell
into this this trap it's not not so easy
to see what's uh what's happening but
yeah I'm not quite sure what what black
some calculation was here because well
he took on d5 let's just tell it right
away till it took him took him 14
minutes and each then he took on d5
however when we see the position coming
up we quickly see how uncomfortable this
is for black so I'm not completely sure
what his rationale was the day I think
they did a press conference afterwards
but it if not did not watch that yet um
what black probably should do is play a
slow moves yeah rookie aid or something
rookie aid possibly Bishop c8 trying to
trade trade this this night off I mean
white is better here yeah let's say even
the capture is not not a terribly bad
idea check gaining the bishops and the
space like back here and then trying to
play on the queenside black ass um leg
doesn't have some great counter play
white is slightly better at least but I
think he still had to do that after
Knight takes d5 there was a big problem
and we would see now yeah maybe you can
have a look there if you want to trade
this is a little puzzle it's um it's not
a purely tactical one but very nice to
to look at yeah what did Carson play
maybe take a take a few moments and then
try to find out what you played yeah I'm
going to tell you the move he went
Bishop to h6 it's a very strong move the
problem is that now the night he hangs
of course and g7 also hangs and tower
should like defend there's really no
choice you have to take their chechik
and white captured now we see that white
is a pawn down but well the pawn is
essentially like h7 or h6 so they're
both pretty much pretty much worthless
and whites compensation for the pawn is
really tremendous he has a unchallenged
night on f5 which is very strong and can
easily be supported by Bishop h3
sometimes 93 and black spawn on c7 is
also quite backward and doesn't play a
huge role at the
yeah white has a great position here so
I'm not quite sure why I'm black allowed
allowed that I mean I'm not sure maybe
he saw this and the other position and
thought okay this is not as dramatic but
I think black definitely is in some
trouble here the computer wants to go h5
but I think miss evaluates the position
what I'm saying is that if you give it
to an engine it says that this position
here let's say I'm just putting some
moves out that make make sense and not
necessarily the absolute best ones but
this kind of position for example if you
give it to adini it gives a slight
advantage for white but I think this is
simply not enough why it is much better
in this position I mean yeah if you just
imagine that the bishop on a tree is
controlling this diagonal and why it is
also threatening to put a night on f5
later um in many cases we will have
Bishop traded against this night and
ultimately sacrifice on c5 when the C
file will be opened why just just has a
great pressure for no risk at all so
this is more than just a slight
advantage the whole position i think is
very awkward for black to play he went
king edge 8h for Bishop back yeah he is
interesting calzon could have taken on
age 6 but he didn't he didn't bother
with that it's not a bad move at all you
can take then go back to five but he
just said just basically I decided that
this is not worth taking he concentrated
on getting his pieces coordinated in
relation to the f5 square you have this
kind of thing yeah that's a very nice
position of a wide yeah look at those
two pieces yeah exerting a great yeah
dominating situation here on the on the
light squares very very awkward from
like he took the night off
no eggs and here we come to a moment
we're on yeah where the next move can be
easily criticized and it's definitely
not helping black but I totally
understand why he why you played it I
mean look at this this Bishop here on g7
he is incarcerated it can absolutely not
move and here we see also one reason why
maybe Carlton didn't want to take on age
6 just imagine the pawn on edge six
would be gone here then Bishop to age
six is a move and here well just one
porner it's not a just a better
situation here probably and with the
poll on age 6 yeah this is what black
played know and it ultimately led to his
handsome defeat probably but I really
have a hard time to suggest at the ACM
what exactly is it that black should do
um if I'm really not having a better
ideas right I'm just playing rook c1
look-see for other group 2 c1 and take
on c5 yeah putting enormous pressure
there and this is just one possibility
White's compensation is really really
great year for the pond yeah c6 the
problem with the movies have a look why
it takes rook c8 and now Carlton has a
very strong move Queen to d1 the idea is
to get the Queen on this fantastic
square and yeah it's not much else there
2pm important is that Knight takes e4 is
failing due to Bishop g4 it's a nice
idea keeping this attack and threatening
97 this wins material for white so rooks
is 625 this yeah what a position White
has three excellent pieces on the light
squares a very very harmonious um
picture
f8 ya hear what has a basic choice he
can take f7 with the bishop or with the
Queen and Carlton took with the Queen I
think both moves were good he probably
figured that in an end game without
Queens it will be easier for him to
convert his strategic advantage check
those trades be three yeah note that
black is totally passive now the King
cannot move it is boxed in the bishop
can almost almost not move that it can
go to g7 then to f6 and Becca so you
have a hard time to improve d6 this week
h6 this week and its sequel material I
it doesn't even have something
sacrificed this position is probably a
win for white with excellent technical
play and while we know that consin is
not the kind of player who fails at
technical play at least in the vast
amount of time yeah yeah nice regrouping
putting pressure on t6 yeah like it's
giving up material but well really what
what is it that you should have done
like this let's say you can go here
again take chap this is simply not
defensible in this position this was
taken and like has a little hope for
counter play but Bishop c6 as a strong
move threatening whoopty 7 and there's
really no way to to save this night or
two gap to to to play differently if she
gunite a6 for example what is going to
d5 and down still has everything under
control yeah this was pleasure
like was hoping for this pin but it
ultimately didn't help Luke h7 was
possible after Luke c6 now check this
wins everything so kg6 was played yeah
note that if a to Luke a seven will you
even lead to a pretty easy win after
Luke c 6-r ok too yeah White has four
points against two and very quickly will
get passes that to win the game yeah
this is what black tried back here
threatening this check King there h5
yeah the idea is a meeting net and you
would see how this unfolds again Luke h6
is the idea and here the mating idea
group f7 rook at five is deciding the
game so if black promotes we have check
checkmate this cute check made yeah in
the extra game um that was resignation
right yes here mvl reside yeah very nice
game by the world champion this idea
with bishop age six was quite quite a
static I think 95 Bishop h6 so very nice
way to transform the position into
something that is clear compensation and
very very awkward to defend its not just
the pure quality of the position that is
good for wide but also the yeah the
practical difficulties that are
associated with it it's very very awful
to play this position for black okay
let's have a look now at the final game
of this coverage this is vishy anand
with white playing Wesley so the
tournament leader yeah again efore baby
sheep no default seems that for this
tournament he is focusing more on his
old
old weapon the King point n 2d three
young this is one of them earlier anti
Martian lines a good choice if you want
to avoid the Marshall however d3 is of
course limiting why its options quite a
bit you don't get see 3d for any more
quite obviously yeah black has a number
of options down on b5 is what Wesley
plate Bishop b3 and now he cancelled in
this position Black has a choice and I
for what it's worth we played d6 in this
position the idea being that after
possible a form i can defend with Bishop
to d7 yeah but this is all metal of
personal preference ich acid uh not now
when 93 an interesting idea i'm putting
the night damn ideas can be night to d5
sometimes on nighty to 2 g-3 the typical
regrouping night to g3 just with a
different route not via f1 like that but
via e to black played d 6 a-3 now we
have to as wide take care about the
bishop yeah if y displaying some lazy
move Knight a5 will gain the bishop am
so a three and now rest sleep late night
b8 yeah this is a an interesting move it
done is of course well known this idea
from the brea variation in the Rue Lopez
close main line with 9h 398 in order to
regroup the night 27 places 6 possibly
or the C porn in general sometimes also
to c5 very well known a DM and it is
important to note that this position was
reached earlier this year in the game
kawana with white against restless so so
it's not something that was coming
unexpected to the form of our champion
here with the white pieces
aunt is coming up with one of his
novelties Knight to g5 this looks a bit
crude right what is the idea of this
move first glance your thing okay well
this is crazy f black goes age six what
are you doing then just back what is the
point the point is of course not the
retreat to f3 why does not planning to
just lose two moves after age six he had
something else in store it wasn't
happening I mean age six was not played
but the point of age six can only be to
play the really really cool move f4 this
is nice right f4 yeah what is the point
f4 if black takes the night let's let's
look at this why does all of a sudden
using the open F failure and g6 is a
strong possibility that is in the
position this is a very tricky position
for black to play if you go back just
just to show it Queen age 5 or g6 are
both already leading to a winning
position gee 69 f6 Luke f6 and this is
checkmate than a couple of moves yeah
ruki 8 and Bishop f7 check 95 and my
mouse Queen h8 made unavoidable it's
amazing right how quick this attack is
coming on the Sun yeah better it's noisy
form we can have a look at this a little
bit this is not a skier g6 and then
probably let's look what happens if
there's a slowish move like c6 then why
it will take on f7 and you can take with
the pawn or with the bishop for example
then check three-night back and queen
age five this is a fantastic attack for
white this capture of the of the knight
on d5 looks very very risky very risky I
mean especially considering that it is
something that probably wasn't expected
as an IG 5 it's not a move that pops up
in any engine I mean if you let it show
like okay give me your top eight moves
then there somewhere 95 but the engine
always wants to play 95 age six and then
back and evaluates like okay this didn't
help me much but it also didn't hurt me
much so this was a complete surprise
here for the black player there is
however an alternative and this is to
take on f4 this is also interesting in
this situation of course the night is
still hanging and this cannot be the
point I mean just just to show in this
kind of situation black is totally fine
he has two minor pieces for Luke and
porn and at the moment the rooks are not
doing that much there's also the problem
here in the position and we will see
something comparable later that white
has no clear way forward with his pawns
in the center if white pushes like that
he's in much danger that some d5 move
will actually allow us later jump to a
light square them so this is not a good
idea for white so after age six and four
takes what was my idea I can only guess
but I think probably just back that's
really funny after g5 we have a
situation that is very much like the
Kings gambit yeah with the capture ng5
but it's a king's gambit out of the
spanish very interesting position um i
think even more interesting it's the
move Knight h3 actually the idea is that
if black takes this wide we'll probably
get this back anyway we have just with
Bishop f4
sg5 h4 looks very tricky yeah it is it
is it is funny but white can do this
yeah even in front of his King because
his pieces i just found more active here
and the bishop especially here is very
very strong this is much much better for
white so g phi is probably better but
here white has a typical Kings gambit
style sacrifice takes digs funny it's
really like a king's gambit King age
seven for example keeping this phone
protected and deform it's quite funny if
you give this to an engine it says zero
about zero it says equality and if you
see this a position where white has
sacrificed the piece for 241 pawn and
the engine claims equality then you know
that black is in trouble probably in
serious trouble and if you give the
engine more time it probably will show
that why it is much better here I mean
you can easily see that rights rights
initiative is very strong 22 comes with
the tempo on the pawn the rookies on the
half-open f valve and all those pieces
are not relevant at the moment so it's
clear that white has a tremendous
compensation also for practical purposes
I think it was a very good decision by
so not to play age 6 what he came up
well there's a funny move he just went
back to c6 yeah night was on be eight
then to c6 and now back back to be eight
and so on but the situation has changed
his ideas and this is really quite quite
logical to put the knight on d4 with the
tempo and then reevaluate Bishop a2
94-92 so why does going for a trade THX
takes this is what what happened in the
game yeah I now a very interesting
moment again he now played age 6 so this
idea that was in the position or
a couple of moves ago it's now again um
yeah he reasoned it and actually played
age 6 um an interesting situation is
rising here if like it's not doing that
I would have rather preferred a thought
of a move like C Phi of something like
that trying to ignore this night it's
not so easy to do but I was thinking
that this might be an idea however after
f4 first impression is why just has a
nice initiative that I are using the
rook on the F file and possibly doing
something there with even f5 g4 porn
storm might be on the cards the computer
is not giving light something
substantial here even the opposite it
says it's at best equal for white but
this is not an evaluation that I think
the human player would agree with so
easily first glance it looks nice for
white and I'm not sure exactly um how
the computer is justifying his
evaluation that same one idea might be
to push c4 at the right moment I'm aware
of that but still I understand that this
looked didn't look too attractive for
black iam he went age six ultimately and
yeah trying to play this show me move
yeah okay of course FYI yeah there's no
no way back something like Nadia three
is of course it's possible but it kind
of the athletes it misses the point and
also to be perfectly honest if Annad
wants to do something in this event he
has to get a win in somewhere and well
better do it against the leader of the
event if possible okay f4 and it also
seems to be objectively and at least
very interesting yeah now I'm he took
the piece yeah I took him a long while i
mean i mean fo i think was pretty clear
that this was coming so wee bit
surprised that he took so long
I mean you actually think I think you
have to make this decision when you play
age six probably on the other idea might
be our explanation might be that he had
something in mind but then he found some
some problem with it um him and said he
took it um what else and black again I
can take on f4 this certainly was an
alternative as before the move Knight f7
cannot be the idea here blackest just in
good shape I think this is even better
than the version that we had before as d
5 is very easily coming here black it's
just better so that wasn't the idea
after it takes f4 only 93 can be the can
be the point and hereafter g5 has to be
played if white gets in Bishop F voice
again just better okay g5 yeah now g3
that that must be the idea everything
else doesn't doesn't make much sense um
yeah and this is in fact very
interesting yeah for example if black
takes and white recaptures we again have
something like their kings Cambodia and
the big point is that in many cases here
we M will get compensation with this
week f5 square a possible continuation
from here is the move um d 5v5 night h5
and then I wrote in my notes unclear
yeah if you have a clear valuation of
this position congratulations the vet I
don't know what it is I really don't
know it looks it looks very very very
strange and difficult to evaluate I
think it's really not not clear nor
what's going on here there's an
alternative by the way blank also can
play Bishop age for you
that's also interesting here wyd
definitely will sacrifice the exchange
also king's indian and sorry Kings
gambit style for example this this this
and this intending to go to f5
definitely gives white very nice
compensation for the exchange sometimes
also pawn to f5 Queen f4 as an idea so
many interesting or attacking ideas for
wine yeah he decided to to take the
night straight away pawn takes Knight g4
that's probably the most obvious move
let's aim if black goes back again Queen
aged 5 and tending g6 is killing there's
no defense to this move yeah gee 69 f6
ruge f6 so nothing there black can play
this just letting do I take but it's
clear that here white will just pile up
on the F file and it's just better
without any particular problem arising
from white so this is also to be avoided
nigel is the only challenging move
really yeah and g6 was played the whole
point of this operation focusing on the
f7 pawn very nice yeah how should black
defend he went um he went Bishop g5 yeah
let's start with some of these things um
Knight f6 is again losing very quickly
cannot do that um what happens if black
is just ignoring everything let's say c6
let's in fact not an obvious losing or
something but right for example I can
just put this on the bot we had
something similar earlier
this is just extremely awkward to play
yeah white has the idea g45 comparable
to the game and sure I don't believe in
this position at all the computer is not
as convinced it just gives white
relatively moderate advantage but it
looks terrible in my book yet c6 has
also moved that that doesn't do that
much um move that certainly was
considered i believe is night to h6 many
just retreating the night and covering
f7 here white has a number of options
and he already has a draw in the back
that is always nice to have this is the
draw oops of seven Andrew keV one that
gives white a strong-looking attack but
this very cold-blooded Japan's is
keeping things together queena 3 yeah it
looks very scary I mean imagine to count
to that you have to calculate that one
misstep and your check made it it is
however a draw like h5 for example and
rook air-five again scary but check this
is only leading to a draw with this move
threatening Queen g6 and made but this
is defending very tricky night h6 was a
very serious possibility why does not
have to play like that however he has
other ideas what he can do is he can try
to take on f7 start with that move look
f7 bishop age six takes with the pond
now rook f1 is a transposition to what
we had earlier but here white also has
alternatives you can try this move for
example trying to take with the Queen
and mate and here let's say Bishop f6
takes check and then you can just
continue the attacks on our let's let's
see like this I'm not sure about this
position the computer doesn't like it it
has
it's better but this is still very
tricky to play at least I understand if
if you see it that you feel yeah quite
quite under under pressure here that you
feel like this might be a problem yeah
this is what you play that it's not
clear that it is a mistake at all but
it's maybe not age six was really better
it's I'm very very very concert
conservative here with this game with
this drawing any conclusions in this
attack because it is very complicated
and even using a good computer engine
whatever is not giving you a very
conclusive result if you have limited
time to to check to check variations and
so this is what what happened take
stakes and nine th six again oops losers
quickly yeah rook the 8th route everyone
is the point and black can resign with
the clear conscience yeah okay we event
night age six yeah now after the bishop
trade there's nothing to take this night
on age six but this is a good move an
alternative was to play rook f7 here it
was supposed very much possible as
Knight takes Queen age five losses
immediately and rook takes pawn takes
check king of eight yeah you cannot
check with the night oops as look as one
this win so king of eight and now queen
age five this is a position where I
couldn't really come up with the clear
valuation but I think why the tech looks
very very strong I mean I really does
that's no task that that you probably
would like to have against the strong
player or against any player for that
matter
difficult to evaluate what the best what
the best way to play is a nun played
differently when Queen age five it's a
it's very very comparable bishop is six
yeah I don't know I also looked a bit at
what happens if white is allowed to take
check this then g4g five is decisive
this is a bit a bit similar like this
and now g4 it's really really remarkable
this night now is trapped on the edge of
the board the g5 move g5 threat is very
very problematic it seems that the next
move is probably probably a mistake but
as mentioned I'm very I'm very very
conservative here in my evaluations
Wesley so now played the move c6 and it
seems that if you can believe the engine
look air force stronger um yeah why look
at form the idea is that if white takes
them like is establishing a pawn on f4
that's a very useful pawn to have in
some lines I can give you an example
let's say g5 Queen f8 and now the
capture this is a mistake actually if
you I'd take you on a six and it's a
missed mistake mistake due to poor put
to my notes say G takes h6 simply and
now the problem is that at the moment
the g7 move is blocked and in a case of
this capture all of a son black screen
is right in the thick of things here and
here and it protects this this is really
awkward so it's much better for why to
play king g 2 and this position that's
much better and here white still has
some chances to play for an advantage
but it is not clear to me at all let's
say it plays rupee 8
like that how would this might continue
an idea that I had was to check on f4
now Queen takes rook everyone is very
good for white now we see that this is
no problem at all so it takes and then I
thought maybe King f3 trying to open up
the G file so that we may be can take on
age six and play g7 using the Jeep on
but it's not a clear situation at all
black might play something like this you
go Rupe to one rupee seven yeah h4 let's
use this move as well we have time to
take d five ticks ticks um yeah I can
chat again this take now and let's say
queen here quindi eight and this is not
clear again I'm not sure what this is
yeah at first I thought what is better
but maybe that's not really the case
black always has some counter play with
Queen deform there is no easy tactical
wind i mean the computer says 000 of
course that's a really deep line it just
shows the enormous possibilities that
were in this position maybe really rook
f4 was much much better move than what
he did yeah he played this c6 move no
Alan took on f8 check g5 immediately
also was a was an interesting
alternative maybe a slightly stronger
one but yeah there are limits but you
can look at in an analysis this was a
very um yeah something not obvious but
it was relatively easy to see a
continuation that definitely Nets wide
something um however still it's not
clear to me that wide win CM look f8
oh gee takes h6 check to acccess the
check they're here this looks very nice
for why deal with the g porn but is it a
win I'm not completely sure and I'm
showing you I queen of 6 h-4 yeah now he
played is the move d5 and it seems that
this is not the right way to play but it
is very difficult very difficult I mean
what I'm basically doing is I look
through the game I'm just to show how
how I analyze this think thing myself a
little bit make some annotation and then
compare it to the engine and the engine
pointed out that this is a serious
mistake that didn't occur to me at all
but later I understood why this might be
a mistake if black is not playing d5 he
has an additional defensive resource and
this resource is the following let's say
a black place and move like um what what
did I have in my notation let's say move
like a 5 kind of a nothing move write a
five and white rice h5 cementing this
pawn & h five what do I have let's say
c5 and now how does white continue here
let's say you place Queenie r3 having in
mind that this is a very good king
important game probably winning one it
should win now see 3d for this is of
however completely irrelevant because
black has this opportunity here this is
a very strong move the ideas that the
trade now is it directdraw as this is a
counterpart on equal grounds f4 ng6 just
this is just a totally equal and how
does white ever get ahead here against
the Queen on f4 white has a hard time to
enter you can try this but then I'm
stepping back and how are you making
progress now we would see the difference
in the game yd
five didn't help them I think this was a
tougher defendant is black is still in
trouble but I'm not playing d5 seems to
be better let's have a look in there at
the game d 5 h 5 g falls played before
King g7 and now Queen f3 the idea that
we saw very so before the big difference
is however if black is going for this
now why takes and go see 5 this is only
possible because the porn it's not on d6
anymore and now white is just stepping
up and picks up everything so this
crucial defensive idea it's not possible
anymore and black has to play passively
and I think this is losing this is
simply losing its too passive yeah ana
now opened up the center and was able to
to invade check yeah it was it wasn't
possible to defend this anymore black
covers the e6 horn let's say so I'm
sorry let's say let's say like this
white is just taking and then pushing
this to promotion yeah yeah it was a it
was a losing end game the final touch is
coming coming short length quite shocked
quite nicely played by Anand in this
situation not quite or is this head to
Syria he played the the nice move d for
me that's a that's a very nice move the
ideas that if black takes it with the
pawn and his kind of out of alternatives
then why it has a very simple win in
Queen f7 just transposing into a winning
King opponent game like this for example
check and white pics are both pawns and
promotes his peep on yeah so a great win
for the former former world champion
vishy anand against the formula now
former tournament leader wesley so
yeah based on a nice opening idea at
this night g5 move a very interesting
way to get new life into this this type
of position with F for coming up also a
clear point of the move d3 the early d3
move that kept the rukon everyone yeah
we had a very very sharp and-and-and
complicated game them where it was
difficult to tell where exactly Lex
mistake was yeah um it was very tough to
get get to grips with this game I hope
you enjoyed my my overview there I'm bit
hesitant to call it analysis because it
was not very deep actually I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching